[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer et la soirée dans les Yvelines
voici les titres de ce lundi 3 juillet
et des rassemblements devant toutes les
maires ce midi l'Association des maires
de France appelait à la mobilisation
pour dénoncer les attaques visant les
élus locaux en plein contexte des
mesures ben l'une des plus violentes
s'est produite ce week-end à
L'Haÿ-les-Roses dans le Val-de-Marne
près de 150 bâtiments municipaux aurait
été attaqués depuis mardi dernier nous
étions à la mi-journée à Guyancourt
Élancourt et Maurepas Joséphine Coleman
berger et Elmer de plaisir sera avec
nous en plateau
une semaine après la mort de Naël qui a
déclenché ses émeutes les violences se
poursuivent notamment dans le
département la nuit dernière a été
certes plus calme mais la situation
reste tendue comment mettre fin à cette
crise nous en parlons avec nos invités
Rudy enzynga président de l'association
Jeunesse sans frontières avant que la
jolie et également Guillaume dordes
secrétaire régional du syndicat à Lyon
police nationale 78 et puis dans le
reste de l'actualité le sport le
Football Club de Versailles un nouvel
entraîneur retour sur la dernière
rencontre en baseball entre les Cougars
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux et le stade de
toulousain et enfin les boxeurs de la
team Farrugia bientôt sur le Ringo
Luxembourg on en parle en deuxième
partie des missions et ce sera en votre
compagnie michaeloro bonsoir journaliste
sport bien sûr de la rédaction TV 78 et
je le disais on va parler sport et on va
parler box notamment ce soir
de boxeur en boxer dans les prochaines
semaines au Luxembourg on parlera
également de Victor webmanyama qui a
signé un énorme contrat avec les Spurs
de San Antonio c'était ce weekend
c'était enfin officiel également de
Wimbledon avec Caroline Garcia qui vient
de se qualifier pour le deuxième tour on
n'en dit pas plus et Arthur Riner le
Saint-Germain qui jouera demain et le
boxe notamment vous le disiez puisque on
a deux invités qui sont déjà avec nous
en plateau ils sont avec nous en plateau
alors comment comment vous préparer ce
combat tant qu'il Fallout déjà bah il
est déjà il est très attendu parce que
ça fait longtemps qu'il a pas boxer il
voulait passer pro absolument donc on
est en grosse préparation pour
il commence à la préparation on va dire
physique pour bien souffrir et après on
va on va faire du sparring à partir de
demain et pour essayer d'être le gagner
avant la limite le jour J voilà
pas encore totalement mentalement oui
je travaille pour faire en sorte de
l'être le jour J voilà et vous serez
peut-être tout à l'heure rejoint par un
autre boxeur Calvin m'a dit qu'il était
déjà venu sur ce plateau peut-être aussi
lui qui prépare aussi ce combat au
Luxembourg on aura l'occasion d'en
parler tout à l'heure il y a également
Céline Charles dans les rédaction tv78
bonsoir Céline et avec vous dans un
instant ce sera les informations du jour
à retenir dans les Yvelines mais ce sera
juste après avoir jeté un coup d'œil aux
prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
une journée est plutôt fraîche ce mardi
dans les Yvelines avec des éclaircies
prévus dans la matinée les températures
17 degrés dans les secteurs de
Versailles et Mantes-la-Jolie 16 degrés
à où dans et même 15 degrés à
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi la pluie
se devrait se joindre à la partie un
maximum de 22 degrés côté mercure plutôt
dans le département minimal à 20 degrés
autour de Rambouillet et demain nous
fêterons les Florent le point à présent
sur l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
actualités des derniers jours bien sûr
Céline marquée par ces émeutes émeutes
urbaines dans le département des
Yvelines lui mouvementée aussi la nuit
dernière une semaine après la mort de
Naël et les émeutes urbaines se
poursuivent un peu partout dans le
département c'était le cas notamment à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux cette nuit et
dans le weekend c'est ça en particulier
les commerces qui ont été touchés dans
la nuit de jeudi à vendredi mais aussi
de vendredi à samedi plusieurs magasins
du centre ont vu leur vitre fracturée et
certains commerces de la place Claudel
ont même été complètement pillées et
vandalisés on peut le voir sur les
vidéos les destructions ont été parfois
très violentes on écoute la réaction
d'un commerçant on est triste notre
société est allée on est triste de voir
que à Montigny-le-Bretonneux trois nuits
d'affilée voire quatre nuits d'affilée
je peux dire maintenant parce que on est
lundi matin les les biens des
commerçants ne sont pas protégés les
biens des commerçants je vous le
rappelle ce sont ceux qui font vivre vos
villes ce sont ceux qui
de la verrière notez également que la
circulation des bus est tramway est à
nouveau arrêté au plus tard à 21h ce
lundi en Île-de-France dans l'actualité
également ce week-end le président du
Sénat Gérard Larcher a présenté sa liste
en vue des élections sénatoriales de
cette année tout à fait candidat à sa
succession il conduira la liste une
équipe pour les Yvelines qui comportent
8 non leur des dernières élections les
républicains avaient remporté 5 sièges
sur 6 sont soit en septembre c'est donc
de conserver ses sièges et dans des
crochets un sixième alors sur cette
liste on retrouve en plus de Gérard
Larcher les quatre autres sénateurs
sortants Sophie prima présidente LR de
la commission des affaires économiques
Michel Laugier membres du groupe Union
centriste Marta de Sidrac président du
groupe d'études économie circulaire du
Sénat et Toine bourra conseillère
communautaire de la Communauté de
communes car d'Yvelines trois nouveaux
noms font leur entrée sur la liste Éric
Dumoulin le maire de Chatou et de
suppliant le maire de Versailles
François Demazières et Cécile de bon
mère de moissons le projet de la liste
devrait être détaillé dans les
prochaines semaines on Gérard Larcher et
Sophie prima avec l'équipe qui
m'accompagne représenter
les IV c'est être utile à mon pays
m'engager m'engagé pour mon pays et je
dois dire
être une des douches du Parlement on
s'est tant d'incertitude notamment avec
l'absence de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale nous donne une responsabilité
particulière et je pense que j'ai une
responsabilité avec pardonnez-moi
d'expérience qui est la mienne de la
transmettre à l'équipe et de la mettre
au service de mon pays je crois qu'on
est dans une période de notre vie
française dans laquelle on se repose
tous sur les élus locaux qui ne sont pas
assez mis en valeur et pourtant c'est
eux qui tiennent la République donc être
moi à leur service c'est une passion et
un devoir
des élections qui auront lieu en
septembre prochain de nappe phréatique
des Yvelines sont contaminés par un seul
vent potentiellement cancérigène c'est
une information de nos confrères du
Parisien lors d'une campagne nationale
de recherche de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire menée sur deux années
la présence du solvant 1,4 dioxane a été
détecté dans les nappes phréatiques de
France et surtout d'Île-de-France dans
les Yvelines deux des trois sites
analysés ont eu des résultats supérieurs
à la limite Saint-Martin-la-Garenne et
Mareille sur le Mauldre l'un de présente
une concentration maximale à 4,8
microgrammes par litre c'est le record
en France le 1,4 dioxane est un composé
chimique qui ne fait pour l'instant pas
l'objet de réglementation en France mais
qui est pourtant classé cancérigène
possible pour l'homme par le Centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
l'agence a annoncé de nouvelles
investigation sur les sites concernés en
vue d'une potentielle réglementation
hospitaliers les hôpitaux de
Mantes-la-Jolie melon Les Mureaux et
Poissy Saint-Germain-en-Laye on dévoilé
eux leur organisation pour cet été oui
des mesures ont été prises pour assurer
le fonctionnement de ces trois
établissements cet été à Meulan Les
Mureaux jusqu'au 31 août les urgences
seront fermés tous les jours de 17h30 à
7h du matin il faudra donc se rendre à
l'hôpital de Saint-Germain-en-Laye les
services des urgences gynécologiques et
obstraiteries obstétricales sera quant à
lui fermer du 4 au 21 août les futurs
maman seront donc orientés versantes et
Poissy tout en sachant que l'accès aux
urgences pédiatriques de Poissy et
régulier par le 15 à Mantes-la-Jolie ce
service continue de fonctionner mais
avec des conditions plus strictes si
l'état de l'enfant ne nécessite pas
d'être vu en milieu hospitalier sera
orienté vers les pédiatres de la ville
on termine avec l'évacuation de deux
immeubles à Maisons-Laffitte donc évacue
après un risque d'effondrement notifié
par les autorités tout à fait plusieurs
commerçants adjacents et toutes les
personnes résidentes des immeubles 12 et
20 avenue de longueuils ont été évacuées
plusieurs axes de circulation dont la
rue des plantes sont interdites aussi
aux abords des immeubles en cause un
risque d'effondrement qui se réduit aux
vibrations des voitures la situation
devrait durer une quinzaine de jours
selon le maire de la ville Jacques
Millard merci Céline pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes témoin
d'une actualité qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news
vous l'avez compris l'actualité encore
largement marquée par ses mesures ben
déclenchées après la mort de Naël ce
jeune de 17 ans tué par un policier
mardi dernier lors d'un contrôle routier
à Nanterre parmi les violences observées
ce week-end l'attaque samedi du domicile
du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses dans le
Val-de-Marne après cette agression de
nombreux rassemblements étaient
organisés en soutien aux élus locaux
devant les mairies de France exemple à
Guyancourt Maurepas et Élancourt avec
Gabriel Gontier Mathilde Franco Baptiste
Roland et William Morel depuis de trop
nombreuses heures nos policiers nos
gendarmes et nos sapeurs-pompiers sont
mobilisés partout en France nous avons
néanmoins franchi un nouveau cap dans la
violence le problème c'est que les lois
et la culture de nos dirigeants ne sont
plus adaptés à la situation des
rassemblements un peu partout dans les
Yvelines et lui habitant était nombreux
à avoir répondu à l'appel de
l'association des maires de France à se
réunir ce lundi à midi
trois jours après la taxe subie par la
famille du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses dans
le Val-de-Marne et dans le contexte de
tension et d'émeutes qui touche le
territoire les mers ont répondu à
l'appel à se rassembler se rassemblement
s'est décidé hier il était tout à fait
normal que j'y participe à la fois parce
qu'il est arrivé à notre collègue maire
de L'Haÿ-les-Roses qui est absolument
insupportable et on le ressent tous dans
notre cher mais aussi pour en profiter
pour passer un nouvel appel au calme à
mon repas aussi se rassemblement était
indispensable pour le maire de la ville
il faut appeler à l'ordre républicain au
calme et l'objectif maintenant c'est
d'apporter des solutions nous ont
développons maintenant depuis nous des
années sur notre territoire
donc voilà l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'était surtout de rappeler que nous
soutenions nos forces de l'ordre et
l'ensemble des élus de la France une
soixantaine de personnes étaient
également réunies à Élancourt pour
suivre le discours du maire et
réaffirmer leur soutien aux élus nos
administrer
ont envie de faire remonter à leurs élus
ce qu'ils vivent ce que ça les a quand
même inquiété et puis montrer bien sûr
que les les mers sont sont là et que ils
n'ont pas l'intention de céder à ce
genre de Chantal qui est contre
l'intérêt général un sentiment que
partage les habitants des communes qui
tenaient à répondre
à tel comme semble tout à fait
de nos élus étant donné que c'est
maintenant on voit que c'est le surtout
le tissu finalement
républicain qui a attaqué donc moi je
pense que on est la majorité silencieuse
on nous entend jamais d'habitude là
c'est l'occasion de montrer qu'on est
quand même là faut il faut que les deux
camps arrivent à trouver les solutions
qui vont dans l'intérêt du pays parce
que on est appelé à vivre ensemble et à
cette jeunesse ce serait bien ça serait
dommage que elle soit comme ça paumée
perdu tout ça c'est une énergie qu'il
faut exploiter bien encadrer et les
écouter en soutien auxédils Emmanuel
Macron recevra 220 mères victimes
d'exaction à l'Élysée ce mardi
et pour parler de cette actualité deux
invités m'ont rejoint en plateau
Joséphine Coleman berger bonsoir bonsoir
maire de la commune de plaisir lui aussi
de nombreux incidents à déplorer durant
ce week-end et dans la nuit dernière on
va en parler avec vous en face de vous
Rudy qui est avec nous aussi bonsoir
vous êtes vous le président de
l'association Jeunesse sans frontières
associations qui travaillent avec les
jeunes de Mantes-la-Jolie qui œuvre sur
le lien social humanitaire et l'objectif
c'est la culture et l'art pour un monde
meilleur il y a également aussi avec
nous par visio-conférence Guillaume
dordet bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes vous donc secrétaire
du syndicat secrétaire régional du
syndicat Allianz police nationale dans
les Yvelines première réaction Joséphine
Coleman's berger alors peut-être déjà un
point à plaisir sur les rassemblements
qu'on a vu se dérouler un peu partout en
France à Plaisir combien de personnes
sont venues à la journée plus de 250
devant la mairie ce matin j'étais
d'ailleurs très surprise que il y ait un
retour aussi vif de la population alors
qu'on a annoncé ça hier soir mais on a
senti non seulement je dirais une envie
forte d'être là mais aussi une grande
émotion vraiment très très grande
émotion parce que tout le monde ressent
la même chose c'est-à-dire où on va quoi
c'est très très inquiétant même si on
sait que les choses se sont calmées la
nuit dernière mais aujourd'hui on est
véritablement sur une difficulté de
compréhension puisque il y a une attaque
qui est une attaque vis-à-vis des
piliers de la démocratie et de la
République donc on peut comprendre
certaines choses peut-être mais en tout
cas les réactions qui ont eu lieu ces
jours-ci nous fait nous font comprendre
que il y a une
difficulté peut-être à dialoguer avec
avec ces jeunes donc je pense que on a
encore beaucoup travaillé à faire je
crois vraiment le président de
l'Association des Maires près de 150
bâtiments municipaux ont été victimes
d'attaque là on a lui-même plus loin ce
weekend avec on disait la taille du
domicile du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses ça
vous fait quoi justement de recevoir ce
soutien de voir que nombreuses personnes
des habitants
d'autres représentants puissent venir à
ce genre de rassemblement je pense que
c'est important parce que justement les
élus aujourd'hui on est plutôt je dirais
dans un dans un regard qui est mitigé
puisque aujourd'hui on prend des
décisions qui sont des décisions qui
sont pas forcément les nôtres qu'on nous
impose parce que l'État aussi se
décharge de pas mal de choses sur les
collectivités du coup nous on est en
première ligne on donne l'impression
qu'on n'est pas forcément à l'écoute de
l'habitant puisqu'on est obligé de
prendre des décisions parfois un peu
dures et le fait d'avoir les habitants
qui viennent à nous pour nous dire qui
sont là qui savent qu'on est là pour
pour eux pour défendre la cité pour
défendre la ville j'aime pas trop ces
mots guerriers là ça ne me plaît pas je
préfère parler de tristesse et de
douleur et je n'aime pas en plus le côté
binaire il y a des gentilles il y a des
méchants c'est pas du tout comme ça
qu'on fonctionne en tout cas moi je
fonctionne pas comme ça à plaisir je
crois qu'il y a des choses à mettre en
place des vrais décisions à prendre que
l'on n'a pas pris jusqu'à présent mais
des décisions intelligentes et pas des
décisions extrêmes
quel regard vous portez justement sur
ses rassemblements de soutien aux élus
on a vu les élus qui ont été visés alors
pas forcément que les élus mais aussi
les bâtiments municipaux les mairies
c'est le cas à Mantes-la-Jolie il y a
l'annexe de la mairie de Mantes-la-Jolie
au Val Fourré dans le quartier du Val
Fourré qui a été incendie et qui a été
détruite par un incendie oui du coup
nous la premièrement on l'a vécu on a
mal vécu parce que c'est aussi un
structure qui est là pour aider les
familles qui pour aider les habitants
mais quelque part c'est jeunesse là on a
comprend parce qu'à partir du moment où
elle est pas écouté elle va supprimer
autrement et c'est pas au moment de la
crise justement où il faut être ou faut
être dans la réaction mais plutôt dans
l'action dans le quotidien et c'est ce
qu'on Martel un peu à toutes nos à tous
nos partenaires c'est vraiment de de
continuer à faire des actions de
continuer à être là pour eux les
entendre à les accompagner et comme la
mer le dit à l'instant c'est important
de continuer à travailler parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de travail encore beaucoup de
travail donc le fond de la colère vous
le comprenez la la forme on a quand même
moins du mal à la comprendre cette forme
de colère
dès qu'on regarde de l'histoire de
France on peut voir que quand même le
peuple français était un peuple de
révolutionnaire quelque part je dis pas
que je suis pas en train de de
cautionner ce qui a été fait mais on
regarde que là on pourra on va écouter
les jeunes parce que le geste a été fort
et je ne dis pas que qu'ils doivent
continuer c'est pas du tout ce que je
dis mais on a l'impression que le
dialogue n'a jamais été voulu n'a jamais
on n'a jamais tenté de nouer le dialogue
et c'est là que
c'est difficile pour la jeunesse parce
qu'ils se sentent pas écoutés c'est ça
que nous on voit au quotidien c'est ça
qui fait éco chez le chez le jeune juste
avant d'entendre Guillaume dardet
peut-être une réaction de fines vergers
moi depuis des années ça fait 20 ans que
je suis en politique je m'aperçois qu'on
fait énormément de choses des
associations comme celle de Monsieur il
y en a pas mal et même beaucoup on fait
beaucoup d'actions aussi vous savez sur
les quartiers et donc on est un petit
peu aussi désolé de voir que ça ne porte
pas ses fruits donc peut-être que on
n'est pas dans la bonne démarche mais
j'aurais quand même rajouter quelque
chose je crois que il faut pas oublier
le les fondamentaux c'est à dire
l'éducation familiale c'est quelque
chose qui est important aujourd'hui on
voit des jeunes de 13 14 15 ans jusqu'à
17 ans qui sont sur la rue à 3h du matin
je suis désolé de le dire je me demande
parfois où sont les parents il y a un
moment donné il faut peut-être se poser
des questions donc il y a toute une
trajectoire à refaire il y a peut-être
eu des loupés il y en a certainement
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui et demain
on pourra le dire au président de la
République je crois qu'on a pas mal de
choses à lui dire demain
juste sur l'aspect élu locaux mairie
visé vous observez aussi dans les
Yvelines à l'image de ce qui s'est passé
dans le quartier du Val Fourré des des
bâtiments publics des bâtiments
municipaux qui sont souvent pris pour
cible durant dans dans ces derniers
jours
oui tout à fait déjà ce weekend on a
malheureusement constaté des incendies
et un incendie sur une école élémentaire
à Versailles sur des locaux associatifs
à Limay et à Poissy on a les locaux de
la police municipale aussi du Guyancourt
qui ont été incendiés donc effectivement
malheureusement ça continue mais on
parlait aussi la semaine dernière de ces
écoles et on en parlait aussi ce soir de
ces écoles incendies dans la commune de
La Verrière josyline colmazurger vous
faites partie de ces 220 maires qui vont
être reçus demain par le Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de cette rencontre avec le
président de la République pas grand
chose c'est pas bien de dire ça mais je
veux dire déjà on est trop nombreux pour
pouvoir vraiment échanger je crois qu'on
est tous dans la même situation de
colère et de douleur je veux vraiment
dire douleur parce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on ressent moi la colère c'est
pas quelque chose qui m'anime je suis
plutôt dans une démarche de construction
et si on arrive vraiment à évoquer avec
lui certaines choses je crois qu'il va
falloir aussi prendre des décisions
réelles
avec aussi savoir que nous on est là les
élus les associations on est présent et
on doit être ce lien avec le
gouvernement pour faire comprendre ce
qui se passe sur le terrain il s'agit
pas toujours d'injecter de l'argent
c'est pas ça le but l'argent c'est une
chose mais il faut aussi comprendre le
terrain et le terrain qui est porteur du
terrain mais ce qui sent nous les élus
on a été pendant des nuits sur le
terrain avec les forces de police et les
pompiers parce qu'il fallait qu'on les
accompagne et qu'on les aide justement
pour essayer d'être sur le territoire et
c'est la qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il
y avait des jeunes qu'on connaissait et
qu'on accompagnait des gens déjà dans
des activités c'est là qu'on comprend
pas très bien ce qui se passe donc ce
mal-être là il faut qu'on le fasse
comprendre aux présidents et surtout qui
nous fasse confiance on les connaît bien
on est là on est présent avec les jeunes
on les côtoie on connaît leurs prénoms
on sait qu'ils sont ils travaillent avec
nos médiateurs avec nos éducs ils
travaillent avec les enseignants donc
c'est ce que je dirais demain au
Président je veux dire au président
attention d'être trop loin de nous venez
nous voir écoutez nous faites quelque
chose mais si soit du concret et je
crois qu'on a pris beaucoup de
retardé le président de la République
peut-être aussi une réaction sur ce que
disait Joséphine Coleman berger sur le
rôle des parents aussi qui est très
important bien sûr et après voilà on
peut on peut le voir chez nous que
parfois on peut des familles peuvent
avoir des complications justement à
l'éducation qui peut être voilà perçu
différemment et là justement les
associations les collectivités doivent
être là pour prendre le relais je prends
l'exemple un peu de notre ville ou les
CBS ou les maisons de quartier ne sont
pas ouvert le soir alors que c'est là où
les jeunes ont plus besoin d'être
écoutés d'être canalisés d'être encadré
et ça je trouve c'est aussi un défaut
d'organisation c'est un détail parmi
tant d'autres mais moi je trouve ça je
trouve important que que justement qu'on
fasse confiance sur le collectif
collectivités et les collectivités nous
fassent confiance sur le terrain qu'on
renoue un dialogue et qu'on qu'on
retravaille ensemble
et ça c'est c'est pour moi le mode pour
faire un petit état des lieux dans les
Yvelines alors au niveau national il dit
il est dit que la nuit a été plus calme
et est-ce que vous faites le même
constat dans les e-mails est-ce que vous
avez des chiffres à nous relier sur les
émeuts de la nuit dernière
alors oui effectivement l'année dernière
c'était c'était plus calme que que les
nuits précédentes donc c'est tant mieux
on a entre guillemets que quatre ou cinq
véhicules qui ont qui ont brûlé quelques
quelques poubelles également mais rien à
voir avec la nuit d'avant
un plaisir qui est la situation c'est le
même constat ça a été plus calme c'est
exactement le même constat mais on l'a
vigilance est là je l'ai dit aujourd'hui
à la population qui était là devant
l'hôtel de ville je leur ai dit qu'on ne
baissait pas je dirais la surveillance
entre guillemets parce que il s'agit de
bien sûr de les rassurer et puis aussi
parce que c'est notre rôle impératif
d'être présent donc tant qu'on n'aura
pas passé une bonne semaine je dirais
avec avec je dirais les relations que
j'ai avec la police et les pompiers de
savoir que les choses se calment
véritablement on va rester très très
vigilant ensemble malgré la fatigue que
l'on peut avoir les uns et les autres
mais je pense que la fatigue elle est
des deux côtés donc ça va peut-être
porter ses fruits
blanches à mon actif et j'avoue que
voilà c'est quelque chose que l'on
ressent physiquement mais moralement
également donc on est beaucoup plus
sensible et j'essaie de pas tomber
justement à la fois dans la colère comme
je disais tout à l'heure ni dans le
bateau c'est bien
certainement mais on va être derrière
j'ai vu que la région voulait
accompagner on verra ce que fait l'état
des départements bien évidemment va
accompagner en étant vice-présidente
j'ai déjà entendu le président le dire
donc on sera aux côtés avec nos moyens
et moi en tant que mère j'accompagnerai
les entreprises les commerces et tous
ceux qui ont souffert pendant cette
période vous l'observez aussi à
Mantes-la-Jolie sur ces dernières nuits
là on sent un retour au calme mais après
on reste on reste vilain on reste
vigilant sincèrement on essaie aussi de
pas se être débordé par nos émotions
donc on continue sur notre ligne de mire
sur notre ligne directrice c'est-à-dire
de continuer à faire des efforts sur le
terrain de continuer à recevoir les
jeunes malgré la par exemple l'annexe de
de la Mée de quartier qui a été brûlée
voilà elle a été elle a été vite
déportée sur une autre structure et les
actions et continuent l'accompagnement
et continuent on baisse pas les bras
mais voilà on essaie de vraiment avec
toute la force de qu'on a dans dans
notre ville de d'essayer de continuer à
pérenniser nos actions ça va être ça
Guillaume dardet vous attendez à quoi
dans dans les prochaines nuits est-ce
que selon vous la calmie va se
poursuivre ou les violences pourraient
repartir est-ce que vous avez vous avez
déjà pas des estimations mais des
projections peut-être pour les nuit
prochaine
non mais c'est très difficile de se
projeter alors on reste on reste
vigilant effectivement on reste prudent
voilà on attend de que ça passe vraiment
sur plusieurs jours et on s'attend aussi
malheureusement au 14 juillet comme tous
les ans il y a toujours un petit peu de
violence urbaine voilà on Tendo jusqu'au
au moins jusque là vous voyez réagir sur
le 14 juillet c'est toujours une nuit
assez sensible oui on a toujours été
très très vigilant on va renforcer
évidemment les contrôles nous on le fait
dans le parc du château donc les entrées
seront vraiment surveillées on aura on
aura soin si tu ne fais de populaire et
familiale donc on a cette responsabilité
d'avoir vraiment une surveillance accrue
ce soir-là et permettez-moi malgré tout
je dirais avant de conclure parce que je
ne relais pas les oublier mais de
remercier tous ceux qui ont participé et
qui participent encore la police
nationale les polices municipales et
puis les pompiers bien sûr et puis aussi
toutes les associations qui travaillent
avec nous c'est important de les
remercier parce que tout le monde tout
le monde a vraiment œuvré pour ça
quelques pistes déjà j'aimerais aussi
vous entendre Guillaume dordet comment
selon vous on peut aller vers une
situation de de fin des violences alors
sur le territoire français mais là en
l'occurrence on parle du département des
Yvelines
c'est difficile à dire mais c'est vrai
que ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure sur
votre plateau c'est vraiment la vérité
c'est je pense que un accompagnement
envers les familles qui ont du mal à
éduquer leurs enfants et leur expliquer
que un enfant de 14 ans parce que ça
reste des enfants n'a rien à faire
dehors avant 22h en pleine semaine voilà
déjà ça peut passer par là et s'il y a
des problèmes de d'éducation il faut il
faut les accompagner il faut les aider
si on aura déjà gagné tes sentiments
actuel là qui prédominent chez les
policiers des Yvelines est-ce qu'il y a
un sentiment d'épuisement là on est
quasiment à une semaine d'émeutes
désormais en France
oui effectivement ça commence à comme
comme disait madame la mère tout à
l'heure on commence nous aussi à être
fatigué enfin les collègues commencent à
être fatigués à enchaîner des heures
supplémentaires et et oui bien sûr ça
devient ça devient compliqué
de polémiques qui ont agité les
dernières heures il y a eu un communiqué
d'alliance justement votre syndicat
aussi d'une ça police qui appelle je
cite au combat contre les nuisibles et
les hordes de sauvages je cite également
demain nous serons en résistance et le
gouvernement devra en prendre conscience
et puis alors ça n'a rien à voir avec
alliance mais il y a une cagnotte aussi
qui a été lancée par le polémiste Jean
Messia en faveur de la famille du
policier qui a été l'auteur du tir
mortel elle a recueilli plus d'un
million d'euros si vous ne pensez pas
que ça risque de jeter de l'huile sur le
feu et pas d'aller vers l'apaisement
écoutez les termes qui ont été utilisés
sur les communes sur les communautés de
presse nous les assumons parce
qu'effectivement quand vous êtes sur la
loi publique et que vous avez des scènes
de guérilla urbaine ben voilà on n'a pas
d'autres mots donc effectivement ben on
est obligé de d'utiliser des mots forts
pour pour qu'on puisse en parler et pour
que les autorités puissent agir
il y a des élus politiques qui ont parlé
de risques de sédition justement face à
ces propos qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça
écoutez après je vais pas polémiquer
là-dessus mais c'est vrai que on est en
difficulté sur sur le terrain enfin mes
collègues en tout cas et alors je
comprends que les termes puissent
puissent éventuellement choquer mais je
pense que les gens qui sont choqués
c'est ceux qui ne voient pas la réalité
en face et qui pense qu'on est encore
dans un pays de comme on dit souvent
dans la dans la police un pays des
bisounours
ils ont choqué vous en plateau ce sont
des propriétés
qui me choquent parce que on est aussi
alors évidemment on n'est pas au front
comme et la police mais comme je disais
les élus ont été sur le terrain la nuit
justement pour accompagner aussi tout ça
donc on a vu des choses clairement on
les ressent pas dans notre cher
peut-être comme les policiers mais en
tout cas il y a des mots qui moi me
gênent il y en a deux dans le communiqué
particulièrement qui me perturbe parce
que je crois que oui on est sur le
terrain on connaît et on sait qu'ils
sont ces jeunes pas tous mais en tout
cas on sait et pour moi les choses
excessives
me perturbent vraiment je crois que
c'est pas par ce biais là qu'on va
arriver à créer un lien aussi avec eux
donc oui j'entends la colère j'entends
l'inquiétude la fatigue tout ça mais
sont des propos trop forts pour moi en
ce qui me concerne moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous pour moi des
infantilisent un peu ces jeunes là parce
que si on compare un peu aux gilets
jaunes ou quoi que ce soit les réactions
sont différentes les mots sont
différents on peut parler de révolution
mais dès que c'est la ça touche à la
jeunesse on parle d'émeutes et là les
mots ils sont lourds et on a plus
l'impression qu'on a qui a des enfants
en face et là le si le problème et eux
ils se sentent du coup exclus après et
on arrive à un cercle sans fin c'est ça
de la haine qui est qui perdure et qui
perdure entre justement le le corps de
voilà la police et cette jeunesse là et
moi ça ça me fait mal d'entendre des
mots comme ça ça me fait sincèrement mal
parce que connaissant la jeunesse la
réaction elle est elle est spontanée
elle est médias elle est émotionnelle et
c'est c'est pas la solution c'est
absolument pas la solution non pour
terminer sur cette thématique justement
quel est le message aujourd'hui que vous
voulez faire passer aux jeunes peut-être
qu'elle aussi qu'est-ce que vous avez pu
enfin quel sentiment prédomine chez eux
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous avez pu
dire échanger avec eux c'est un
sentiment d'injustice la situation du
gène Naël c'est ça a fait cocher chacun
d'entre eux c'est réellement parce que
voilà ils ont déjà tous pour la plupart
vécu des situations compliquées mais je
suis pas du genre à dire c'est soit noir
soit blanc parce que moi personnellement
j'ai eu à faire à des policiers qui ont
été extrêmement bien verts donc c'est
tout ça pour vous dire que c'est pas
soit noir semble un soit blanc donc
c'est c'est assez nuancé mais ces
personnes là qui vont manquer de
bienveillance et qui vont faire preuve
de d'agressivité et voilà qui vont être
à la à la source de ces agissements
c'est aujourd'hui eux qui doivent être
puni donc ce policier là il doit
répondre de ses actes là parce que la
mort de ce jeune là n'est pas la
première et n'est peut-être pas la
dernière en tout cas on espère un
plaisir on va continuer le travail
j'imagine avec la jeunesse des quartiers
oui on est en plein de dons depuis de
nombreuses années entre la cité
éducative la réussite éducative enfin il
y a énormément d'actions on a plus de 80
actions toute l'année avec les jeunes
sans parler tout ce que l'on fait au
niveau du sport et de la culture donc on
va continuer on n'est pas du genre à
abandonner bien évidemment et on est
partenaire de nombreuses associations
donc on va continuer je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il faut il
faut persévérer et je n'aime pas
entendre sa puissance fond parce que ça
voudrait dire que faut pas le faire au
contraire il faut continuer mais il est
clair qu'aujourd'hui le dialogue est un
peu distante du donc c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué il va falloir qu'on
revienne encore une fois et encore plus
dans les quartiers il y a pas que les
quartiers d'ailleurs dans ces quartiers
là auprès des jeunes pour leur faire
comprendre que on les écoute on les
entend surtout parce écouter c'est bien
mais il faut les entendre et puis faire
davantage de réunions peut-être aussi
avec la police en tant que police de
proximité quelque chose qui a disparu et
que je trouve dommage parce que
aujourd'hui quand il y a des actions
possibles de rencontre entre les jeunes
et la police ils se comprennent
davantage il y a des choses à faire
aussi là-dessus pour comprendre que il y
a pas de monde on vit dans la même
société aujourd'hui c'est notre rôle à
nous adultes de les rassurer aussi mais
il y a des choses qui sont quand même
inadmissibles je ne porterai pas de
jugement sur le décès des uns et des
autres malheureusement il y en a des
deux côtés et je laisse faire la justice
parce que là je ne me prononcerai pas
mais en tout cas on a encore beaucoup de
choses à faire et nous les élus on est
prêt à le faire davantage de proximité
guillaume dordet est une réaction à ce
qui a été dit aussi en plateau mais
davantage de proximité ça peut être une
solution aussi
oui ça peut être une solution aussi mais
pour cela il faut il faut des moyens il
faut des effectifs et surtout nous en 78
on a on a très peu de sorties d'école et
maintenant de nouveaux policiers qui
arrivent donc pour le mettre en place il
faut du monde
bah les élus vont être reçues par le
Président de la République est-ce que
vous souhaitez vous être reçus aussi
dans par le Président de la République
peut-être aussi pour lui faire remonter
les problématiques de terrain
alors moi même non mais effectivement
mes responsables on souvent contact avec
avec le ministre avec le président et je
sais qu'il passe les bons messages et
effectivement ce sera ce sera évoqué ça
c'est certain les mots avec vous
Rudy vous comptez travailler aussi sur
cette thématique au sein de
l'association sur la thématique actuelle
des violences est-ce que vous comptez
travailler là-dessus avec avec les
jeunes de l'association dans les
prochains mois on a déjà travaillé déjà
sur une pièce de théâtre autour
justement des violences urbaines des
violences policières là où justement on
a appelé justement la responsabilisation
à la responsabilisation de chacun des
parties entre guillemets donc la police
de l'état des gènes des parents et nous
on continue notre travail au quotidien
mais il est aussi l'idée c'est aussi de
les sortir aussi de ce tourment de cette
problématique parce que la vie c'est pas
justement que que ça c'est pas que
justement l'affrontement c'est aussi
plein de belles choses et une fois sorti
de de cette actualité de ce de cet
épisode il sera temps justement de
partir sur des choses nouvelles et des
vraiment des belles choses c'est là que
que les solutions vont aussi se
multiplier c'est là aussi que le
développement des jeunes vont va se
faire et donc nous on mis sur ça sur des
actions quotidien on va sensibiliser
aussi mais on va pas s'arrêter que là on
va aussi ouvrir sur voilà sur le
culturel sur des vraiment des belles
choses c'est c'est ça ce dont les la
jeunesse a besoin merci à tous les trois
d'être venu en parler en plateau je le
rappelle Rudy enzinga président de
l'association Jeunesse sans frontières à
Mantes-la-Jolie Joséphine Coleman berger
maire de la commune de plaisir je
précise et je reprécise à nouveau vous
allez être reçu demain par le Président
de la République vous faites partie de
ces 220 maires de France qui vont être
reçues par Emmanuel Macron à l'Elysée
merci également à Guillaume dordes
secrétaire régional du syndicat à Lyon
police nationale 78 qui était avec nous
vous le voyez par visio-conférence la
suite du 7 8 avec la page sport
[Musique]
on commence par du baseball c'était l'un
des chocs du week-end en première
division les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux deuxième avant la
rencontre jouer ce week-end contre le
leader du championnat de Stade
Toulousain et les 5 continents repartent
avec une défaite mais une défaite mais
aussi une victoire dans leur valise
explication dans ce reportage de Michael
el midoro et Mélanie poquet
gagner pour se rapprocher du haut du
classement ce dimanche 2 juillet les
Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
recevait le leader de la poule Stade
Toulousain après avoir remporté la
première partie la veille sur le score
de 7 à 2 les inhymontins n'ont pas
réussi enchaîner lors de cette seconde
partie trop brouillon il s'incline sur
le score de 10 à 3 on n'a pas manqué de
grand chose si on a manqué peut-être un
petit peu de frappe mais ce qui a
vraiment été
négatif aujourd'hui c'est la défense on
a fait quelques erreurs et du coup dans
des matchs de haut niveau comme ça ça
pardonne pas donc malheureusement on
prend des points assez bêtement là
dessus
on a joué hier et on joue le lendemain
c'est pas évident pour le corps faut
pouvoir le remettre dedans et des heures
en défense qui nous mettent je pense
mentalement un peu au fond
et on a pas réussi à se relever
malheureusement on l'a déjà fait on sait
le faire et on espère le faire pour la
fin de la saison après ce bilan d'une
victoire et une défaite sur ce week-end
au stade Jean maréchal les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux pointe à la
troisième place de la poule avec un
bilan de 12 victoires pour 8 défaites
donc là il va falloir qu'on aille
jusqu'au bout des choses il y aura pas
le choix il va falloir tenir jusqu'à la
fin de saison là on peut potentiellement
aller chercher les playoffs si on gagne
tous nos matchs après si on en perd un
ça va être ça dépendant de de résultat
des autres donc là ça va être plus
compliqué prochaine rencontre pour les
Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce
dimanche 9 juillet ils joueront contre
les boucaniers de La Rochelle les 2e du
classement
non non non
[Applaudissements]
retour de Mickaël el midoro en plateau
et aussi des invités qu'on va parler box
à présent dans cette édition il disait
tout à l'heure deux boxeurs de la team
fort oujob vont être sur le ring le 22
juillet prochain au Luxembourg il y a
donc Ibrahim Fofana qu'on a présenté
tout à l'heure également ce qui nous a
rejoint c'est Calvin Madjid bonsoir
Kevin et donc votre coach également
Tanguy foire Oujdi alors peu de premier
premier tour de parole on va dire
comment vous préparer la ce combat qui
arrive le 22 juillet prochain Kelvin
c'est-à-dire comment je le prépare
comment comment vous vous approchez
cette date on va dire moi je m'entraîne
je montrais je m'entraîne dur je suis un
petit peu au régime aussi là je suis
dans ma catégorie contrairement au
combat précédent donc ça va un peu mieux
niveau régime mais bon je fais quand
même attention à ce que je mange je suis
quand même au régime mais je me prépare
je me prépare dur catégorie Super coque
c'est ça et du coup
Ibrahim ben on vous l'a posé tout à
l'heure la question mais comment vous
vous préparez à l'approche de ce combat
pareil on a on a prévu un programme de
de préparation pour le combat donc
j'essaye de le suivre au mieux pareil je
suis aussi sur un régime là actuellement
donc on perd le poids petit à petit on y
sera le jour J et voilà à côté de ça on
se prépare aussi bien physiquement que
mentalement pour le jour J faire le
travail qu'il faut en catégorie léger
c'est bien ça super léger et comment
coach Tanguy Farrugia travaille avec ses
boxeurs sur ces dernières semaines
on est dessus
on est dessus on a le plus dur c'est
trouver des sparlings et surtout dans le
mois de juin au mois de juillet quoi
donc on est dessus on avance petit à
petit puis
je pense que le jour J on va être
explosif Kelvin vous êtes sur un bilan
de une victoire une défaite vous avez
deux combats chez les professionnels
pour l'instant là c'est un petit peu le
tournant on va voir si si vous allez
avoir une victoire de plus ou une
défaite de plus bah on va tout faire
pour la victoire on va tout faire pour
la victoire c'est ce qu'on fait quand on
s'entraîneur c'est ça on est focalisé
sur la victoire et pour aussi donner un
bon combat mais mais oui effectivement
on veut sortir de la victorieux vous
sentez que vous grandissez au fur et à
mesure des combats ouais ouais je sens
que pour mon premier combat déjà rentré
dans le milieu professionnel ça a été un
gap et bah pour le deuxième en plus je
suis sorti victorieux donc j'ai senti
que que j'ai pris un petit peu de niveau
un peu plus de niveau on en avait parlé
de Kelvin il y a quelques mois sur ce
plateau énorme potentiel comment vous le
trouvez toujours là c'est ce qu'on
disait on attend la réponse du champion
de Luxembourg qui a été aussi en équipe
de France voilà et on attend on attend
ça je le trouve qu'il y a c'est dommage
qu'il est pas trop un peu trop tard mais
je pense qu'il a
les capacités d'être j'espère entendre
le championnat d'Europe minimum avec lui
alors
Ibrahim pour vous ça sera votre premier
combat chez les professionnels vous êtes
tout nouveau pas trop de stress quand
même pour l'instant non je pense que
plus on va approcher de la date et plus
ça va un peu monter mais pour l'instant
non en tout cas je gère comme il faut et
sinon ben on attend la date avec
impatience ça fait longtemps que
j'attends le combat là en l'occurrence
mon dernier combat est date du mois de
novembre donc ça veut dire je me suis
beaucoup impatienté et là j'attends
vraiment que la date elle arrive
d'accord c'était pas chez les
professionnels j'imagine non et vous
connaissez votre adversaire mon
adversaire non mais sinon en tant que
boxeur non je connais pas la même chose
pour vous Kevin vous connaissez pas
votre adversaire je m'intéresse pas
tellement moi mes adversaires je laisse
ça à mon coach oui je crois savoir que
tonifa oujdio vous étudiez avec
assiduité tous les adversaires disons
qu'il y a beaucoup de couleurs alors
point fort leur point faible il y a
beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de boxeurs
d'entrée d'entraîneur qui qui étudie le
box moi j'évite que c'est un souci moins
pour le boxeur voilà de penser pour eux
et de voilà ça a passé on a battu le
champion de France avec Kelvin voilà
donc on va essayer de renouveler ça
alors qu'est-ce que vous pensez
d'Ibrahim on a parlé de Kelvin mais
comment vous voyez Ibrahim ben moi
j'espère qu'il va qui va percer aussi
qui va percer aussi là on va voir son
premier pas chez les pros voilà et à
partir de là on va commencer à viser
mais c'est sûr que
Ibrahim on vise des titres c'est sûr il
a il est plus jeune j'espère qu'on va
oui qu'on va faire des choses alors vous
allez au Luxembourg pour combattre le 22
juillet pourquoi le Luxembourg est pas à
la France finalement disons que la
Fédération Luxembourgeoise m'appelle
pour trouver des combats
que la France m'a paye pour payer des
taxes malheureusement on en est là c'est
c'est compliqué la France t'as pas le
pape la Fédération Française de Boxe
n'appelle pas pour pour boxer box pro du
moins donc là on propose des combats
certes ils sont pas très bien payés mais
au moins tu bosses
voilà donc la différence elle est là
c'est c'est juste bon c'est vrai que tu
fais deux combats dans l'année propose
deux combats deux ou trois combats dans
l'année mais au moins tu les as voilà
qu'en France
on attend sur le ring ça change de boxer
en France au Luxembourg Kelvin parce
qu'il change c'est que quand on est à
l'étranger on n'a pas notre public j'ai
pas mes proches pour venir me voir pour
venir me soutenir et on est souvent du
coup en terrain entre guillemets hostile
c'est ça qui change après sur le ring en
tant que boxeur maintenant le le la
personne en face c'est un mec comme moi
ça change pas qu'il soit luxembourgeois
belge français peu importe
tu as fait la Belgique
et pour vous premier combat
professionnel du coup
Ibrahim c'est pas une pression
supplémentaire non pour l'instant non je
pense que ça va venir quand même
l'impression parce que je suis en boxeur
qui se met quand même
assez impression même si j'arrive à
gérer donc je pense qu'avec le temps
plus on va se rapprocher de la date plus
ça va monter mais après j'espère bien la
gérer et faire ce qui est faire ce qu'il
faut pour gagner le jour J bien sûr et
quel est votre style de box mon style de
boxe
très bonne question
je dirais j'irai un style plutôt
français on va dire globalement je suis
assez polyvalent donc c'est à dire que
je sais je sais boxer en reculant quand
il faut je sais boxer en avançant après
mon style de prédilection c'est un style
plutôt en français et on va dire style
que j'aimerais avoir c'est le style à la
mexicaine on va dire plus ou moins la
mexicaine c'est ça moi je suis j'aime
les bâtons voilà
disons que c'est vrai que j'aime les les
combats où il y a du contact mais aussi
le public aime aussi le les combats qui
ont des contacts si on met deux
stylistes ensemble le public va
s'ennuyer il faut qu'il y ait des
oppositions que tout le monde boxe pas
de la même façon
qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
ce combat Kelvin Ibrahim quelle victoire
en bonne santé surtout
ressortir son dégât en bonne santé et la
victoire
Ibrahim
la santé et la victoire je m'en
occuperai une première victoire
professionnelle sera le 22 juillet
prochain en tout cas du côté du
Luxembourg on va suivre la suite avec
attention merci à tous les trois d'être
passé en plateau pour en parler on va
continuer de parler sport de l'actualité
sportive ça bouge à Versailles Michael
oui on connaît désormais le successeur
de Chris le FC Versailles annoncé ce
samedi 1er juillet le nom de son nouvel
entraîneur il s'agit de Laurent
Peyrelade l'ancien joueur professionnel
de Nantes du Mans encore de Lille arrive
avec près une expérience de 7 ans au
club de Rodez avec cette équipe l'homme
de 53 ans a réussi à faire monter le
club aveyronnais de la Nationale 2 à la
nationale une puis de la nationale une à
la Ligue 2 le club s'est ensuite
maintenu en Ligue 2 pendant 3 saisons
avec un petit budget la montée en Ligue
2 ce sera justement l'un des objectifs
de Laurent à Peyrelade pour y sera
accompagné au poste d'entraîneur adjoint
de Grégory Vignal les deux hommes
dirigent leur première séance
d'entraînement à cette semaine et cette
semaine et ça a repris du côté de
Bougival
cette année on va parler à présent de
basket lui aussi a signé un contrat son
contrat mais on parle quand même d'une
autre dimension là oui on prend la
direction de la NBA les sons Antonio
Spurs sont annoncés ce samedi que Victor
Wemba nyama avait signé son contrat
après avoir été drafté en première
position de la draft le 23 juin dernier
le genre originaire du chinero concours
va toucher environ 55 millions de
dollars sur quatre ans sous réserve que
les Spurs activent une option pour le
conserver sur les deux dernières années
vendredi prochain livelinois de 2 mètres
21 disputera la Summer League de Las
Vegas avec la franchise on continue par
du tennis le tournoi de Wimbledon qui a
débuté aujourd'hui du côté de
l'Angleterre des yvelinois sont engagés
dans la compétition aujourd'hui il est à
saint-germain-nois scarling Garcia
jouait le premier tour de Wimbledon
contre l'américaine Katie à vollinette
un duel dont elle est sortie vainqueur
quelques interruptions dues à la pluie
la tête de série numéro 5 du tournoi a
gagné en deux sets sur l'herbe le score
6 4 6 3 en moins d'une heure trente
demain ce sera autour d'un autre évier
noir de participer au prestigieux
tournoi de Wimbledon le Saint-Germain
Arthur rinderknech sera opposé à son
compatriote Alexandre Muller au premier
tour des simples messieurs il sera le
grand favori de cette confrontation à
noter qu'il n'a jamais dépassé le
premier tour de ce tournoi on croise les
doigts pour lui on aura peut-être
l'occasion de débriefé tout ça dans la
prochaine mission si on parlait sport
sur sur TV 78 on termine avec un mot de
course à pied les inscriptions pour les
Foulées de Maurepas viennent d'ouvrir
cette année la course à pied programmée
ce samedi à 14 octobre au programme
ainsi c'est un 12 km sur route et dans
les bois de Maurepas et un 6 km pour la
marche nordique chaque année plusieurs
centaines de participants s'inscrivent
pour ce rendez-vous merci Michael pour
ces actualités sportives bientôt la fin
du 7 8 mais juste avant on va jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil aux prévisions météo
de demain
une journée plus fraîche ce mardi dans
les Yvelines avec des éclaircies prévus
dans la matinée les températures 17
degrés dans les secteurs de Versailles
et Mantes-la-Jolie 16 degrés à Houdan et
même 15 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi la pluie devrait se joindre
à la partie un maximum de 22 degrés côté
mercure plutôt dans le département
minimal à 22° autour de Rambouillet
voilà c'est la fin du 7 8 merci de votre
fidélité j'aurai plaisir de vous
retrouver dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]